let me ask you about something you wrote
about this week Middlebury College
because I am so worried about liberalism
and it's one thing it's so easy for us
all to be United because obviously Trump
is the ultimate villain I mean it's
Rocky three he's got mr. t to fight I
worry that liberalism is at a perilous
point and I know you write about this
and you wrote about Middlebury College
we not aware what happened with Charles
Murray who's been a guest on the show I
don't agree with him liberals don't I
think what he talks about although he
claims to be a social scientist he does
research is thinly veiled racism but
there is a way to fight that and that is
to debate him to bring up points that
you can actually look up in books what
you that's not what we saw at Middlebury
show the tape this is and this is this
could be any college by the way when a
speaker is invited and this is what
happens yeah that's that's the free
speech yeah I know what it leads to this
big climates of shut it down shut it
down and afterwards a mob actually
attacked there's a good aircar and yeah
and a female professor has a has it had
it suffered a concussion this is this is
not an argument this is a religion bill
this is the kind of secular religious
you you have to believe if you're on
campus you have to believe certain
things or you are a heretic what you saw
here was the burning of a heretic they
don't want to hear other ideas because
it will upset them will hurt their
feelings a point of a university is to
make you uncomfortable is to show you
ideas they're going to actually offend
and make your life a little more
difficult and so you can figure out the
answer to them yeah I
[Applause]
outrages and Inter sensible and every
level the university any college that
people who can be identified who
physically prevent some of the speaking
should be disciplined including
expulsion and there will be criminal
prosecution of those thugs who
physically attacked them the only I was
dealt with is I don't think this
represents liberalism this is a small
group of younger people right is often a
campus excuse me let me finish and it's
over to the Millennials in general so
but you dr. bill didn't say Millennials
he said liberalism I reject that as a
description of most liberals I think
most liberals were unhappy with that
opposed to it and critical of it yes it
was out ready to fight that liberals are
having their there there is a division
as it's a very small group and I agree
some younger people by the way I've
spent a lot of time on campuses there is
no gig where they pay me to go and talk
to students I like it and I have not
found the problem is could I like you
they get you having to get in something
you don't have a problem on Kayla but I
did four with them on some stuff but
they I find there is an intimidation
factor I do not think I'm on a bet that
if you polled the students at Middlebury
a majority would not have agreed hate
that it is also the faculty bill guys
are rapidly cementing this death
teaching this stuff in bulk and my
parents there was something very wrong
with the parents and the way they raised
their little brats that is the
problem it's all because tonight but I
want to get soul in one thing but I can
clearly there's outrageous in a
violation of civil liberties and and
want to be repudiated but I also I'm not
prepared to take the answer oh well but
you know they feel so strongly don't you
understand that yeah well they felt so
strongly they should do something about
an effective ways I'm going to bet you a
lot of those people who were doing that
outrageous
suppression of free speech sat out the
last presidential election right oh I
particularly resent it when people who
were not there when I was trying to make
a hard fight to stop what we're now
dealing with now coming well they gotta
resort to these kind of
you look at students who are claiming
that the Yale leadership is white
supremacy when you actually have a white
supremacist running for president right
and they were not even interested in it
whatsoever
no because they'd much rather attack all
the Liberals and conservative